okay hello everyone welcome to this
lecture so I'm this is what you I'm a
postdoc in Chelsea lab today I will give
the lecture about domain generation
um so before we start I will first go
through some logistic things so the
project Milestone is on Wednesday and
the homework 4 which is an optional
homework is due unmountain
here's the plan for today today I will
introduce A New Concept called domain
generation uh I will first do some
problem statement and problem
formulation and then introduce two kinds
of Representative algorithms as the
first one is to adding Express
Distributors to solve this domain
generation problem and second one is we
can leverage some data augmentation to
handle this problem
and the goal for this lecture is that I
would fulfill first let you know how to
understand the intuition behind the
domain generation and there's a problem
formulation and I will also see that you
can be familiar with the mainstream
domain generation approach uh so the
regularization based approach or
augmentation based approaches
so let's first do some recap about the
domain augmentation that we learned from
our last lecture so in the domain
adaptation we aim to use some training
data from The Source domains and make it
perform well on the target domain this
is a kind of a form of transfer learning
but we can also access to the Target
domain data during the training process
so it is transductive learning so we
basically we have the training domain
data and the unlabeled Target domain
data and we want to perform well on the
tax domain
so there are two common assumptions for
the domain adaptation and the first one
is the source domain the target domain
only the full in domain of the function
so it means the conditional distribution
y p y given X is the same between the
source and Target domain
and there also exists a single head
process with a low error on both source
and Target domains
I will also do some revisiting to see
that a domain is a special case of tasks
so a task is composed of three
components the first one is p i x is for
the marginal distribution of feature
distribution another one is for the
distribution of if the domain of the
function the p y gamma X and also the
loss function so in for one task that we
learned from the mid task learning or
methylene all these three components can
be changed from different tasks but in
the domain only the p x can change over
different domains
mm-hmm so before we start so then we
will mention that can we always access
unlabeled data from the target domain
however in some real world applications
because of the following two reasons
that we cannot always access this target
domain
the first one is sometimes we want to do
real-time deployment and we do not have
time to collect enough Target domain
data and to do the adaptation including
domain adaptation or collect label data
to do some methylene or future learning
adaptation
and in the case that obtaining the
target data may be restricted by the
privacy policy
and I will provide some examples for
each of these reasons the first one is
for the real-time deployment and in this
case for example if we want to change an
autonomous driving system and we want to
let this this models train on three
types of rows and then we want to deploy
this model to a neural for example we
want to deploy this on on the night and
in this case we want to do some
real-time deployment and we do not have
a sufficient time to collect enough data
and another case is about the other
example is about the privacy concerns uh
so there are a lot of uh private
policies about the privacy concerns so
for example the most famous one is about
General data protection regression is uh
which is from Europe and in this case we
cannot share data between different
institutions or hospitals or any other
stuff and for example if we want to
build a disease predictive model so this
disease predict model we change on the
three hospitals for example Hospital one
two three and then we they want to
deploy this model to a new hospital
and in this case to deploy this model to
a new hospital we cannot access the
training data due to some privacy
concerns
based on these two things I will first
to mention why we need domain General
relation and the first to give some
formal problem formulations for this
in dimensionalization so assume we have
a bunch of source domains for example
there are three domains the clipart
painting and sketch we want to recognize
different objects for each domain
and we will change a model and to get
such a neural network this is a
regarding a trained model and then we
will deploy this model to some UNC
Target domains here is a domain for the
real image
and we want to generalize some common
knowledge from The Source domains and to
make its models perform well on this
target domain
mathematically is a domain generation
problem could be formulated as we given
a bunch of source domains pyx1 to pnx1
we aim to solve UNC Target domain ptxy
without accessing the data from it
so they are similarly there are also two
common assumptions
as the first one is all domains only
differ in domain of the function it
means that the conditional distribution
p y g m x is the same across different
domains in our previous definition
definition of domain adaptation we will
make the conditional distribution to be
the same between the source and Target
domain and but here it will be exactly
the same across all domains so only PX
can change
uh so the another assumption is that
fair events are single hypothesis with
low error in all domains
so that which currency that we can learn
a model that can perform well across
different domains
okay so this is also elevating for the
automated spatial case our task so it's
also holding the domain generation
problem
and based on this definition I will try
to do some comparison between the method
learning that we learned in a lot of
lectures before and and the domain
generation
and in methylene we it is kind of like
transfer learning and we want to
transfer some knowledge with many Source
tasks
so given the data from task one to n we
want to solve a new task T more quickly
proficiently and stably
and in domain translation this is a
spatial case of the method learning that
we learned before so given the data from
domain T1 to DN we aim to perform well
on the new domain DT
Suppose there are two kinds of
difference between the domain generation
and the methane the first one is only
pix changed across different tasks but
in the mentally we can change a lot of
things so the about three components
and in dimensionalization is we want to
directly generalize to the new domain
instead of doing any kinds of adaptation
yeah this is the basically the
comparison between meta learning and the
domain generation
on as a second comparison is between the
domain adaptation that we learned from
our last lecture and domain generation
or in the domain adaptation we can
access some label we can access the
label data from all Source domains and
we can also use unlabeled data from the
target domain
so we aim to make the model perform well
on the target domain
and in this case the target data we can
access the target data during the
training process so we can access the
unlabeled data and which also gives you
some information of the target domain
and in domain adaptation there were only
one source domains typically so but
people can also use more systems but we
can only rely on One Source domains to
achieve success from adaptation
and the model change for the domain
adaptation is only specialized for the
Target domain
so it means we only care about the
performance such as a specific Target
domains that we can access instead of
consider this problem on a more General
case on a bunch of domains
so the adaptation is a one kind of like
a transductive learning setting
or in domain generation these things
would be a little bit different so in
Dimensions internationalization so given
labeled data from a set of source
domains p1x1 to fp1xy to pnxy and we aim
to make the model perform well on the
target domain or a function Target
domain actually
so we cannot access the test data during
the training process so this is the
first difference
and the second one is domain generation
usually needs more than one source
domain so if you only when you have a
bunch of resource domains you can
capture the common knowledge between
Behind These Source domains and then to
generalize this common knowledge to
benefit the performance of the target
domain
and this is the third difference is that
these models can be applied to all
domains including the source domains and
Target domains and even some domains
that we didn't capture
so this is why we need to learn some
well generalized knowledge and can be
generalized both to a bunch of domains
yes this is the key difference between
the term adaptation and the
dimensionalization
in this lecture we want to mention and
domain generation is an inductive
setting
okay
so
So based on this definition and based on
some comparison I would like to show you
some real world applications of
dimensionalization
so first application is about
sustainability and the two we want to do
some Wildlife recognition we would like
to recognize different animals on
different locations so here we will use
for example here we have 245 locations
and we want to change a model throughout
these locations and to generalize these
models to new locations
another examples you may familiar with
because in the last lecture we also see
the automatic adaptation version of this
tissue classification example so we aim
to classify one tissue image whether
it's normal or is tumor so basically we
learn a model from a function of
hospitals and then we change this model
to some new hospitals here is Hospital 4
and Hospital 5.
and the in the term adaptation instead
we probably only have two hospitals and
we want to learn some common knowledge
from these two hospitals
the third application is the molecule
property prediction as a molecule
property production is quite important
in the drug Discovery field so they want
to predict some toxic of given a small
molecule we want to predict the toxic
and we train a model on different splits
of these molecules and different scale
Force and then we aim to generalize some
common knowledge and to make it work on
some unseen scale Force
and the last one is about code
completion this is also very important
applications for example in the field of
programming language so we have a bunch
of reports and then we train a model to
do to predict the next tokens in the
context of source code and then we aim
to generalize this model to some test
distribution
okay so this is the basic introduction
of the watches domain generation and do
some comparison and give some
applications uh next I will introduce
some specific algorithms about uh for
domain generation the first one is I we
I aim to add some explicitorializers to
handle this problem
um so before we dive into the specific
algorithm so let's first think one
problem how to learn such a
generalizable representations
and to answer this question
a natural way is we want to think
another problem is about why do machine
learning models fail to generalize
and here is one very simple example so
our goal is to classify dog versus cat
so there are two domains the domain one
is water and the domain two is grass
and uh we have actually have four groups
so the first one is talking in the water
and the adult in the water and dogging
grass and cutting grass so for dog in
the water and the cutting grass are two
majority classes
uh two majority groups and otherwise
cutting the water and the talking grass
are melodic groups
based on this we change a model on this
Source two Source domains and it can
stream the model and then deploy this
chain model to a new domain for example
uh the dog in as a forest
and our question is is this a dog
a human can easily to recognize this dog
but for computer it is very hard
so in usually in computation it's very
easy to recognize but in this case it's
hard to recognize this adult
and there's a computer will make the
wrong prediction so why this happened
so there are some similarities in the
training data we can see the dog in the
training data.talk is usually in the
water and the cat usually in grass
and then it sees some similar
environments compared with grass and
then the grass would be a spiritual
asparagus information it means since
these models will spariously associate
the
uh cat information and grass information
and that's when it's the computer sees
some similar environments it will make
wrong prediction
so our goal is to cancel out such
various information here and to use this
uh we aim to change a new network to
learn some domain environments
so this is another concept I want to
mention here so the domain invariance is
that we want to learn that feeds a bunch
of features via the new networks that
don't change across different domains
uh in case that we can learn such domain
invariant information for example we can
associate the animals with the labels
and the computer can make the right
prediction
okay yes this is something about domain
variants
and
based on this definition I will send
details regulation based method
the key idea our recommendation based
method is that we want to use a
regularizer to align representations
across different domains
and to get the domain variety
implementation
as let's look back to this example so we
have two domains and the two classes and
two classify the cat and dog
and in this case we can get the
representations for example for domain
one and for domain one we can get the
representations which is composed of two
information as the first one is animal
and second one is water
so we only cover some major informations
in these images and similarly we can get
the representation for domain 2 so it's
also animal and grass
and I hope we can align these two
representations to enforce them to be
very similar
the simplest way to get a small loss is
that
finally this new network can only learn
animal information because the animal
information is shared across different
domains
okay so based on this example I will
then mathematically Define some generic
loss function for that
so this is a typical loss function for
the regularization based method
uh in the first time is for label
classification loss for example in this
we do the we classified dog versus cat
hair
and then we will average the loss over
all training examples
and then we will Define our expressed
localizer to learn the domain valuable
presentation this is the key part for
this regulation based methods so how to
define social localizer
okay so before we dive into this to give
some specific algorithms I will first
recap the domain adversarial training
into my adaptation that we learned from
the last lecture
uh the key idea is that the prediction
must be made based on the features that
cannot be discriminated between the
domains
a foreign
X we will feed this image to our feature
extractor and get the features
and then we have two branches and the
first branch is to do the label
predictor
and we aim to make accurate label
prediction
so in this case because in domain
adaptation we only have the labels for
the source domains so only source domain
only data from Source domain are feeding
to this branch
and second branch is uh our domain
classifier the domain classifier we aim
to make this image cannot we cannot
predict the in as a domain for this
image based on these features so in this
case uh the features we can learn some
domain environment features
so both data from Source a Target domain
can fit into
this Branch because we want to do some
domain classification here to classify
whether white whether this feature is
from The Source domain on from the
target domain
okay and now I have one question so this
is a very simple version for the
adversial training in domain adaptation
so does anyone have ideas on how to use
the Tomato switching in the dimension
relation setting so adding volunteers
versus
are green are real or
for each image
yeah you want to
predict its corresponding domains you
mean
you want to predict if this is the one
or not for example oh yeah yeah
that's right so
yeah there's something that we will
mention here is we have the label
predictor and the domain classifier
and instead of we only feed the data
from The Source domain into the label
predictor in the domain translation
settings we will feed data from all
Source domains into this label predictor
so to predict its corresponding labels
and similarly all the data flow all
Source domains will be filled into the
domain classifier and instead of to
classify whether it's from Source domain
or twice domain because there are no
such definition in the domain generation
settings we will to predict those domain
labels for every image
okay based on this definition so we I
will first uh mathematically give some
definitions for this label predictor and
the domain classified as corresponding
losses
and in the label prediction we aim to do
such a label prediction give the uh give
us an input X and we will extract some
features from F Theta X and then we will
do the label predictor to get its
predicted value with the function G
uh and we will submit for every examples
finally to optimize the uh the function
the parameters of label predictor and
feature extractor
and here the smaller is better because
we want to make accurate prediction in
the source domains
a photo map prediction instead we want
to predict systems but we actually want
to maximize the loss
so the larger loss is better because the
larger loss means it is harder to
distinguish domains for average input
examples
in case where we cannot distinguish
domains we can learn some domain
invariant features and to make it
generable
Okay so
and then we will Bridge from the generic
formulation and the new formulation for
the domain adversal training in domain
generation
uh this is that loss for DNA loss in
domain generation so
the first time would be label
classification laws
and the second term would be will you
design one regularizer to learn such a
domain invariant implementation
and the four algorithms has four steps
uh the first one is that we will
randomly initialize the encoder the
label classifier and the domain
classifier
so we will try to use the domain
classified laws the LD to optimize the
domain classifier
and we will based on this results we
will update the label classifier and the
encoder by considering both label
classified application loss and the
domain classification loss
we will finally repeat the Step 2 and
step 3 until convergence
hello
foreign
are they trying to optimize the domain
classifier to be performed very well
I'm thinking about if you want to do
this
you should have a very good like dummy
classifier so that's it you will force
the representation to be domain
Americans yes
you mean good it's like uh in case you
cannot force a classifier oh yeah yeah
yes this is good yeah
so in case you can make by the loss so
you can learn a good domain classifier
and the image can force the domain
classified
should not be the negative sign in front
of the loss function because we want to
maximize this so this is minimize one
yeah
any other questions
um
do you think this would be more
expensive or less expensive than say um
learning features for your domain and
then
so like my data setting and then um
conditioning on the domain with the
feature extraction for the label
uh so your question is you want to learn
a separate
directions or
so you learn some features for each
domain yeah
a new condition on those features for
the label classification what that
would that be equally expensive
um
okay I see so you you mean you will use
separate encoders and every domains have
one encoder right
yes sort of sort of like extracting
features for the domain
and then
possibly in some cases it's more
expressive in case when you have a lot
of data from every domains so you can
learn a better encoder you without
sharing encoder with other domains but
in some cases you cannot collect so many
data for every domain so in case you
would like to share some representations
and to have a shared encoder yeah
and what happens if you don't know they
don't have information about the domains
like we have a data set and it's not
labeled over domains uh yes these are
very good question so this is something
that we also try to learn so without
considering the domain information uh
there are a few Solutions the first ways
you can try to predict this domain
information based on the data uh and in
some cases if you change eim empirical
recommendation you can also just do some
domain information and to see whether
you can predict it well uh other case
you can find that some misclassified
examples this may be from the minority
domains and you can upgrade these
examples and to make it work
thank you okay
oh
yeah so one question was asking papers
who try to learn shared leading
representation between the tasks and so
you learn the task specific like drawing
specific and the domain common like the
shared share uh shared features please
so how does it relate to the so would
that perform better over this kind of uh
uh to repeat the question so you mean we
separate domains
has its own encoder yeah yeah so you
learn on doing specific languages
uh by maximizing information between uh
the more between the uh different
domains present between the samples that
you have so you can learn the common
representation yeah
yeah two branches two lens uh some two
sums have some specific layers yeah yeah
I think this is possibly more expressive
it's the same question and uh
we wouldn't give you more expensive
power in the testing time like let's say
if you just want to Output particular
feature or particular domain
uh but in the test time you will
definitely get one new domain so you do
not have its corresponding Branch
yes yes
in case you mean you want abundance uh
Atomic specific branches
[Music]
specific ones I just want to clarify
your question
probably I can use some whiteboard so
you mean Sierra while I share the
representation this is shared
and then you have two branches for two
domains
and how to do it for the test
so in the test you definitely need to go
one of some branches
yeah but you do not have the information
for the test time which branch you want
to go
okay
but can't reach no I wasn't thinking
about that I was talking about learning
common religion representation for the
samples themselves for this one yeah so
assuming that that's a legal space yeah
we could learn a common latent space and
the shared latent space and then we
could use a common latent space to then
uh generate the uh even any dough for
any domains
yeah I think this is what we learned
right now to use a shot encoder for
every domain
so let's go back to this one so we have
a shared feature encoder and to go to
Every domain
you were the leaders
oh we currently do not add any
conditions but possibly add some
conditions to enforce
this would be helpful
I mean the key point is that
multitasking only solves a
when the Ching domains exactly the same
from the test domains right but we want
to show some unseen domains
okay
so any other questions
sorry but if you don't have a bunch of
domain labeled data I mean maybe with
the cat dog example earlier you don't
know the grass and water are really two
different domains are going to be a
problem until you are at the left you
try to do it yeah I think uh this
problem is that I mentioned so probably
you can see try to distinguish the
domain information and to do the domain
prediction and then in other case you
can see that how to for example how to
like see that some miss you have changed
video model into eimos and to identify
the misclass effect once these ones
maybe from the majority uh from the
minority domains or from the minority
groups yeah
okay
Okay so
okay let's continue
training so leverage uh adversarial
optimization to learn the domain
environment features so um asks there
are there any other ways to do that
uh then I will introduce one alternative
approach called the Coral in the coral
so the key idea is that it can directly
align the representations between the
different domains with some similarity
Matrix
foreign
adaptation but it usually also used in
domain generation in recent years
so here I will only choose the domain
translation version of this
algorithm so in this one assume we have
two domains further here we want to
recognize different objects
we have some shared layers and this
could be located at the feature
extractor and then we will use features
to fit into some classified to get the
classification loss for every domain so
for the domain one we have one
classification loss and the domain two
has another classification loss
then we will have the colors in the
colors we want to directly makes Alonso
these both representations
uh before we dive into the corals I will
first give some notations uh so the
notation in the X1 is a feature metric
and for the representation and this is
with Dimension N1 times k for the domain
one and the exterior similarly for the
domain two is N2 times k
and the K is the number of features here
and we get the mean value with this
formation formulation and with Dimension
1 times K and similar to the mean value
of the another domain
over all examples
then we will try to calculate some
covariance Matrix in columns the goal
for color is to make these covariance
Matrix exactly similar to control the
similarity between different covariance
Matrix
so in The covariance Matrix this is
something that we learned from some math
courses so to get this covariance Matrix
and finally Define one colors to make
this covariance over features would be
very exactly the same
and this is also the loss for the coral
algorithm
and we will combine the classification
laws for the first time over all
different
examples and we will also design one
color loss to explicitor realize to
learn the domain environmentation so the
key idea for the coral behind the coral
is to
make the covariance Matrix similar for
every domains
is this uh extendable to more than two
yeah yeah it's extendable so you can
directly add more domains for example
domain three four five with one
classification loss and use pairwise
coil loss to do that
so do we have individual encoders for
different domains oh that people will
share the encoders
any other questions
about how much does
model architecture
and our mathematical formulation of the
problem
a matter in this kind of only in
approaching this kind of problems
in generic version of everyone
regularization
mathematical formulation of the problem
helps
so it depends so you know like we can
increase the model architecture from
resonate or even for visual Transformer
you will have more parameters and these
models will be more expressed have
strong Express power and to represent
more information and the design some
regularizers is also very sensitive in
this specific domain generation problems
in case you have a very large models in
case you have the same models same
backbone and we can compare different
kinds of regular Riders and with the
same regularizers we can compare
different backbones
well the limits of each of this so how
much the model architecture selection
affects your performance and how much
can the mathematical formulation of lost
or any
good affect the performance in general
how much power do they have while
I see so
for each of them so for multiple
architectures for the comparison between
model architecture and the dose function
right uh
um for different data sets I think uh
increasing the model as the express
power or model architecture is not a bad
choice so you can definitely increase
improve the results uh but
um
but typically we try to add one
regularizer and this regularizer chosen
localizer can affect the problem also
the performance more you know if we
found a better one so it even hurt the
performance
yeah because if you increase the model
uh Express power so the performance of
ERM will also increase
in case if we can align different kinds
of different order of the information it
would be helpful so think that's the one
you can directly analyze the
representations and in these papers they
consider the second order versions of
covaris so if you can do more but if you
can do more you will have like more cost
computational courses to do more yeah
okay so we can continue
and then for the results I just choose
some results from the office home.net
and DIY camp and in the office home we
have four domains and we will hold one
domains as a test and use another three
training uh other three domains and
training and then to generalize one
model to the test once and we will
repeat the progress for false so for
every domains to do some evaluation and
also we'll do the similar things for the
domain net and for the eye white Cam as
I mentioned before is basically we want
to generalize the model to new locations
to do the wildlife recognition
and we can see the auto Accord
performance well compared with Ein and
then sometimes 100 performance compared
with Ein I think these are the questions
that designing a suitable regularizer is
very important
finally for these kinds of methods I
will mention some points and cons
and
the good things is that the first one is
these methods can generalize well to all
kinds of data Networks
so for example if we want to change it
to graph data or text data we only need
to change the shared layers the backbone
from bird and to graph neural network or
any other layers
um and there are also some theoretical
guarantees here in these kinds of
methods I will not dive into this one
but if you anyone are interested in any
theoretical results please email me and
I will can send you some papers to
discuss this
uh but the bad thing is that these
regularizers sometimes being too harsh
or too constraining other
representations as we can see that the
DN cannot works very well in the some
data sets
and let's also go back to see why
localized being too harsh for example
you see in this one we can go back to
this dog versus cat classification
and these are is uh loss function and if
we directly add the Y Express the
localizes that it will encourage the
internal implementations to only contain
no info about the background but
sometimes it's in the mixture so we also
need some informations to do this
classification or to uh if we do not
have any backwards it even hurt us to
learn a better domain environmental
representations or even hurt the express
power of the new network
foreign
okay
So based on this we can see that in some
real world applications like iOS cam the
core improves the performance but in
some other data sets like R once this is
the medical image classification task so
the code will even holds the performance
so the dyno also hurts the performance
as I mentioned before
are you mask are via any approaches to
relax the dependency of the required
then we let's move to our next part of
the algorithm design so to do the data
augmentation
before before we detailing the data
augmentation let's first recap the space
correlation in the spirits correlation
algorithms to classify the dog and cat
and the background is sometimes
variously corrected with the animal and
though some models cannot make a right
prediction
however one question
in case we can collect more data so we
have the glass data water data and data
as a card domain and the keyboard domain
from both dog and cat
so we want to recognize still recognize
this dog
the question would be will the network
still associate dog with water
background in some Source domains
and you guys want to answer this
question
cannot associated
everyone too
you can still like mainly still just
have dogs in the water background then
it might still just dissociate
oh yeah we do not consider this scenario
so
yeah
uniform distributions
in case
similar weight oh
yeah yeah that's not so because there
are many more backgrounds so we cannot
recognize dogs only with the brass
background
and in this case some models can produce
the right prediction
however there is one challenge
in case that we cannot always collect
model data from the different domains
so what we want to do we aim we can aim
to generate more data and to change this
model
and here we want to introduce some
methods for data augmentation
for example there are some simple
operators that can help us to generate
more data
and in the configuration for example
we're given one image this is the
original image we can use different
operators to generate the data like
flipping rotating cropping or like a PCA
or Edge enhancement or any other methods
that we can generate some image data
based on my image
foreign
we can do some back translation in the
back translation we have one sentence
originally from English and then we want
to translate it to French and then
translate back so the augmented example
would be slightly different from the
original one
and this data augmentations can
typically help us to do the domain
generation can benefit the performance
however this simple operators requires a
knowledge of the problem domain for
example we need to see how this is the
image data of or text data or to adopt
different strategies to do the data
augmentation
our question would be any general
approaches
and so I will introduce one General
approach for data augmentation in this
lecture it's called mix up
in the mix-up the keep idea is to
interpret training examples
assuming we have a land model without
training data so the training data has
any examples with the input and the
label pair the x i y and from I to equal
to n to n x equal to 1 to n and we will
change a classifier based on this
training data
and then mix up aim to replace this
original training data from a mixed
version
um so in this case we will have two
examples x i y i and XJ YJ
and then we will do some linear
interpolation so also like a convex
combination between the x i y and up
between x i and the X-ray and the Y and
the Y drain
so and in this case we can generate some
virtual examples called XI total and Y
tutor
for both features and labels for both
input and labels and then mix up will
use this generated label generator
examples to replace the original
examples and use the new training data
to build a classifier
so here's one example for the mix-up
we can generate some virtual examples
between two classes so the first uh the
image in the left hand side is for the
cat and then next one is for dog and we
can convert them to generate some images
in the between so from cat and dog so
this image helps around 70 probability
to be classified as a cat and 30 to be
classified as talk
so this is a very common and useful ways
to do data augmentation
any questions about the process for the
mix-up
okay
so in domain generation mix up can
itself can improve the performance of
Dimension relationship
so let's see we here we want to do the
tissue classification from chameleon and
also to do some land type prediction in
the land type prediction example we call
assist data set here called the fmlw and
we want to given one satellite image we
want to classify as land types and we
want to generalize from some year and
the region combination to other year
routine combinations
and compared with Ein and mix up can
improve the performance
however it is not always good foreign
examples this is a quite challenging
data set so mix up even hurts the
performance compared with eim
the key draw pack for the original mix
up is that this method only focuses on
the data augmentation instead of trying
to learn some domain variants
so the question is how to improve the
original mix-up
to introduce the next algorithm I will
first give a simple examples with space
correlation so this example can help you
to understand what happens in the next
algorithm
and the example is quite similar to the
examples from the reward image so this
is a toy case in this toy case we have a
lot of green tools and red files and our
goal is the label one is to see this
digit is smaller than 5 and the label 2
is distributed larger equal to 5.
and then we have a Target domain with
similar colors or with the green five
but as the green values from a different
ways as background is green
and fit into a neural network and this
new network cannot produce the correct a
prediction because in the chain part uh
some models spariously associated with
the color with the labels
and so this example is very similar to
the examples I gave before for the dog
and cat classification
okay so based on this example I would
like to introduce Lisa to improve the
original mix-up
as a key idea behind the Lisa is Lisa
want to selectively interpret examples
and to emphasize some invariant
information not only on only on the data
augmentation like mixed up did
so this is like the examples we call it
the colored amnest so we have some two
majority groups and two minority groups
and the based answer build upon the
mix-up uh there's one variant called the
intra-label Lisa in the interlay police
are we aim to interpret examples with
the same label but from different
domains
we just add one simple constraint on the
original mix-up so to make it the domain
is quite different so from d i not equal
to D tray but we will make sure the
labels are same so Y is equal to y j
and we can see in these five images
so first one and the last one I mean the
left one and the right one is from the
original data set so Lambda equal to
zero or Lambda equal to one
and then we can generate some image with
different backgrounds we can see these
three images in between
and all images are associated with the
same label so with digit large equal to
five
and we can see that uh even when we
generate a lot of different backgrounds
all of them associated with the same
label
and in this case the models will finally
ignore this color information and only
focus on the digital information
and to capture these environments
any questions for this
I have a mix-up question in general
um so is it possible
um have people been trying to apply next
up to the tax story oh yeah yeah yeah I
will mention it later yeah
any other questions
yeah I mean if we do not have domain
labels it's a little bit hard to apply
this algorithm or something one simple
solution is that we can try to see
whether we can only mix the examples
with the same label without considering
the domain information in this case you
can also generate some similar things
for this variant
could you do that if the model is let's
say confident on some Target samples
could you use those as a label ground
you mean we want to change our model and
Target the samples
on the target symbols
but the predictions if those have good
certainty like if the model is much more
confident on the samples
[Music]
is like we can use
labels from you can some examples with
some pseudo labels in the Target domain
yes this is another question would be
close to some domain adaptation or
similar surprise the learning settings
yeah we will not consider these settings
here
the data on this
Earth out of either domain distribution
so like if you can show it a blue five
and the Bluetooth does it work better on
those than if you had not done any red
green augmentation uh your question is
that if we have ndl like blue ones or
any auto distribution something like
that yeah it definitely works so for
example we can put this example here as
we change the background from uh from
green to blue so it can still work very
well so because in case you learn some
digital information and then you can
ignore this domain information
okay so another variant of Lisa is is
called the intra domain is initial
domain inside maybe we add some
constraints on the domain level so we
want to interpret examples with a
different label but same domain
so d i is equal to DJ but y i is not
equal to y j
and in this case the left and right ones
are also from the original data set all
these are gratitude and the red five and
we can generate a lot of images in the
between but with different labels
so in this case we can see uh even the
domain information is the same but all
of them is associated with different
labels
so the domain of information is not the
reason for the label changes
so we can also make these models exactly
ignore this domain information and only
focus on the environments focus on the
digital information
any questions for this variant
okay let's move out
in practice
uh Lisa M2 combines these both of them
because each of them has its uh its own
like applicable scopes
uh the first one for the intra label it
works better when there are more domains
especially if you have more domains you
have can have more combination to uh to
in between to apply the intra-label Lisa
and another thing is like the spirits
correlations are not very strong in our
practice that intra level Visa works
better
and instead the interdominantly cell
works better when the domain information
is highly specifically correlated with
the label
so in case for example this data
distribution is quite imbalanced and
there are much more even 99 of uh
according fives and the red red tooth so
in this case the intra-domination works
better
and in practice Lisa used one half
parameter P select to determine when to
use interlabel Lisa or when to use
injured domain design at each iteration
from say you cannot apply either of
these supposing you only have read twos
and great files
okay yes this is a very interesting
question we already investigated in our
anal settings uh this is like in this
case you can see this we call it like
under specification things because these
models can infer the labels based on
background information only or in
informed labels based on strategic
information right we typically want to
help build up models with two heads and
each header represents one kind of
things the first hand may be represent
the domain information I mean the color
here and also another head would be the
label information by sharing some layers
and we will use some unlabeled data to
make two heads produce diff quite a
different output
uh and in this case we can uh when we
have a new domains and the models aim to
classify the labels we can try to
collect a few examples
to speak which heads that we want to use
yeah
yeah the paper please email me and I can
send a web paper to you
previous lectures
um thank you again could possibly use
hey IE it is as part for data
augmentation methods uh
you can even use some to disentangle the
representations and to shift something
between different domains and it can
even improve the performance
yeah but in Pro uh applying cycle can
would be a little bit complex so and
they need more efforts to train or the
hyper parameters
is there any reason though
choose a leader intra-lible or internal
members and the secretary
uh
we choose uh otherwise because each one
have its own pros and cons so in
interest we actually in practice we
should initial level is up more uh but
in some cases in generalization also
works very well
any other questions
yes
[Music]
so how do you how do we decide oh you
choose which labels you randomly pick
some examples I will choose a four
algorithm here so maybe we can take a
look what is process uh
so in the foreign that first stage we
randomly initialize the model parameter
Theta and then we will sample one
straight edge from a balloon
distribution and with the high parameter
P select
and we will sample a batch of examples B
and here this is we will in this stage
we'll choose either entry label is our
introdomination so if s is equal to zero
and we will use initial level Lisa and
for every examples within this batch we
will sample another example that
satisfies y equal to y j and the D I not
equal to DJ
and similarly in English for every
example in the batch with sample one
example that satisfies that the label is
different but the domain is same
we will use some interpreted we will
interpret these examples and interpret
use the integrated examples to update
the model
finally we will repeat the steps three
and four several times until converge so
for every iterations we will choose
either intellable result
[Music]
or classes
for one label you take all domains over
there uh uh you mean for the entry level
one
we will use uh if we have more than one
two domains and then we will for each
examples we will only pick examples with
the same domain but without concerning
the labels
uh I only make the labels are different
yeah
any other questions for the process also
for algorithm
okay let's move on
and here we shoot some results to
compare eim empirical recommendation and
the coral we mentioned as a
regularization based approach and also
Lisa and we mentioned here the
augmentation based approach so the
chameleon is a two-class classification
is a binary classification and with the
solution domains and the fmw is around
the
32 class classes and a bunch of domains
are one is around the third uh
33 classes if I remember correctly and
Amazon has is also a binary
classification Amazon is a text data and
in these four data sets at Lisa works
better than the both coral and eim
and in the Iowa Camp the caller works
better than other methods also in the
ogbt producer
molecule property predictions EI even
works best compared with other medicine
so in this case we can see uh different
algorithms have its own advantages and
disadvantages and you may choose which
one you want to use based on the
experimental results in your practice
so you may also see that Lisa do works
well on the image data but it also works
well on Text data so how to apply mix up
in the text Data because it's a little
bit weird if you apply the mix up on the
input level so on the original Text data
so here I will briefly mention the menu
for the mix-up
in the original mix up we apply the mix
up of the input and then gets the mixer
image and feed into the feature
extractor to get the feature
representations
and then feed the future representation
to the uh to the classifier to do the
more classification
and in the menu for the mix-up we
instead doing apply the mix up on the
input we do the mix up on the feature
level for example in the text domains we
typically do it on the top of both the
output output so we will change the
feature extensor at Birth and apply the
mix-up of the features of the output
output and the image domain I use to see
example here we have the talk features
and the cad features and we will apply
mix up here and get the mixed features
and then feed these mixed features to
the classifier
Okay so
the final result I would like to show
you some invariants analysis
so how to measure the environments
so the direct way to measure the
environment is that when we get the
representations of the environmental
reputations we can try to use these
representation to build a model and like
a logistic operation or any other models
to predict the domains and we will use
the accuracy of the domain prediction to
measure whether we can
find a better environment or not
another mention is that we want to show
is that we will measure the Divergence
of the predictions among the domains so
we'll Leverage The representations of
the predictors the project means the
largest to see that whether for every
classes we can see that give Divergence
between every domains we will have one
distribution about the output the
representation distribution and we will
try to do some pairwise comparison
between different among different
domains
and then we'll stamp the results for
every classes
and so
we compare Lisa with eim also with the
linear mix up the RM IBM IEX is other
methods other kinds of methods for
recognization based methods
and we do have see that Lisa can lead to
Great domain great domain environments
then parameters with some explicit
regularizers
so both a matrix smaller value
represents
greater domain violence
any questions for this
okay
and finally I would like to also do some
comparison between regulation based
versus augmentation based methods
and engine Recreation based methods I
will look up the points and cons the
First Advantage is that it can
generalize to all kinds of data networks
and have some theoretical quarantines
and it but it relies on the design of
localizers also sometimes supervisors
are too harsh
um and in the orientation based method
it is easier to understand and the
simple to implement
and we do not need to worry about how to
design very well generalizable regular
Riders
and but sometimes it's largely limited
to the classification problems also some
problem types if we want to apply some
simple augmentation operators
for tax or the image data
any other questions
yes this is a plan for today
so we introduce the dimensionalization
problem and give us a different
definition for this and we introduced
two kinds of algorithms the first one to
adding explicit regular arises in the
loss function to align the
representations and the second one we do
some data augmentation to generate more
data and to learn domain virus
so hopefully we can reach the goal and
to understand what a dimensionalization
is and also to be familiar with major
domain generation approaches
yeah
any other questions for the entire
lecture or
what about the main generalization for
example
problems uh for sharing the problems
there are not too much domain generating
problems but in cases you have multiple
domains you want to generate for example
uh some
uh some image in one domains and some
imagery in other domains you can also
apply some domain generation problems
directly to change the backbone of the
generating models but they are do not
have too many Advanced Technologies to
apply this
foreign
impression here Perfections
any other questions
okay if we do not have any other
questions so there are also some
reminders so the project I must know on
Wednesday and the next time is the
lifelong learning lifelong learning is
something to combine the techniques that
we learned before so hope you can enjoy
it until next time